we have a very interesting situation
right now
where we are seeing the joining the
melding
of two major stories and one kind of
explains the other
we have on the one hand the questions
that have lingered
because donald trump never released his
tax returns about
whether trump is as wealthy as he claims
whether trump's businesses are as
profitable as he says they are whether
donald trump has
problematic debts to others and thanks
not to donald trump but thanks to the
blockbuster new york times investigation
the answers to all of those questions
are yes yes and yes and in fact there
are a total of 420 million dollars in
debt that donald trump has
300 million of which are loans that will
come due during donald trump's second
term as president if he gets one so
that's one story
okay talked about that yesterday
secondly
we have this story from july which i've
been on top of for a while
which is that the trump campaign is
accused of
uh of of uh laundering money
through its campaign laundering donor
money
and doing all sorts of sketchy and
potentially illegal things with
donor money that i told you about in
july
this is now coming together with the
added
piece of trump's former campaign manager
brad parscale
uh threatening to harm himself and
allegedly
hitting his wife and getting arrested in
florida and i'll tell you how that
relates to it
why is donald trump's campaign
laundering money if they are
well it seems weird to do something so
risky just for kicks
it is explained by the taxes if trump
has 300 million in loans coming due soon
and 420 million in total debt and his
businesses aren't doing nearly as well
as he claims
which was also exposed by the recent new
york times tax bombshell
then the reason he's laundering money
could be
to free up money that was donated to him
for his campaign
to pay back some of those debts i mean
it's the crudest
top level analysis the details could
vary
but that would be a very reasonable
inference from what we are seeing
if whoever trump's creditors are and we
still don't know the full scope of who
they are
if they plan to come for trump's money
starting in the next few years
then trump urgently needs to get cash to
pay them and if we really want to
speculate and this is the brad
parscale piece and now we're going much
further we told you yesterday on the
bonus show that donald trump's former
campaign manager brad parscale
was taken by police to a hospital
because he was threatening to harm
himself he had barricaded himself in his
home he had according to his wife 10
guns with him
his wife reportedly had bruises on her
etc etc anytime someone is threatening
harm to themselves or others we don't
make fun of that that's serious
but the timing of it is interesting
because based on the reports about money
laundering from july
par scales companies were major players
in laundering the money
and at the exact time that the new york
times story breaks which is the
beginning of the unraveling maybe
of the money laundering and of trump's
taxes brad parscale has a breakdown
are they related well we don't know i
mean it is speculative
we do commentary and opinion here that's
what we do the timing makes me wonder
about it very very much
the question in the end is how much jail
time can you end up with
if you launder millions for a sitting
president if that is indeed what brad
parscale did
it could make even the most stable
person maybe lose their cool
we don't know we'll see last thing to
mention here
you can tell that they have the goods at
the new york times
the new york times story about trump's
taxes
likely is completely accurate because
all of the reactions are distractions
some trumpists have been tweeting you
know it's illegal to
leak someone's taxes who gave it to the
new york times
that concedes that they are really
trump's taxes right
or why was this published right before
an election that's
dirty they're trying to influence the
election well that concedes that
these are trump's real taxes right or
who cares if trump didn't pay taxes that
makes him smart well
that concedes that what the new york
times is reporting
is accurate and of course trump has
casually said oh it's all fake it's just
fake news
but 99 of the rebuttals that the right
is running with aren't substantive they
are non-sequitur
what about ism the next five weeks are
going to be fascinating we will see
tonight
in the first presidential debate you've
got to join me live for this thing
we will see tonight at the first
presidential debate uh
whether the topic of donald trump's
taxes comes up we will continue covering
it on our
instagram page david pakman show on
instagram make sure you're following us
there we'll be back right after this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video